wir sind im heimatland von marti fischer
angelangt das wird gleich noch eine
rolle spielen der ja dieses jahr den
secret talents award auf youtube
gewonnen hat denn für niedersachsen wird
antreten bernd begemann und dirk
darmstaedter werden antreten ist korrekt
wir werden antreten und ich sag hallo
mein name ist bernd begemann dirk
darmstaedter musste noch schnell
verschwinden muss hemden für die band
kaufen gibt zwar nicht gut aus sowohl 18
und ab gehen und diesmal vielleicht 5 6
euro pro heft investieren ich finde es
ein bisschen übertrieben aber dieser typ
den grafischen im fernsehen haben alle
machen sich verrückt was soll's wir muss
ich empfehle ja die karierten hemd näher
bei diesem kaufhaus
kann ich verstehen
er wollte ihr tragen bestreift
eu-recht roccos ich würde euch gut aus
ich wollte euch gut aussehende manchmal
gar keine sorgen dass wir die anderen
ohne man sich sorgen
ich meine das gezeichnete ich meine hey
ich meine typ sagt schon praktisch macht
sich sorgen um mich machen sich sorgen
um mich ich bin
gezeichneten von sich von einer
geschichte des scheiterns erzählt ja ich
weiß nicht ich meine das finde ich
seltsam weil wir alle weiß und
mitteleuropäer sind wir sind alle
gewinner hatten wir sind keine opfer wir
bekommen gar nichts dagegen tun wir sind
nutznießer also kommt man damit klar
dass es gut für einen läuft ich komme
damit klar und ihr solltet auch damit
klarkommen und nicht mehr so viel
kräftiges zeichen und wirklich wirklich
nicht ich bin sehr unzufrieden mit euch
hier spielen sich als opfer auf das ist
eine beleidigung gegenüber richtige
opfer er holte opfer sein ich mache euch
zurück von kultur
okay das war jetzt klappen der ausflug
mehr so in diese gangster rapper szene
kann ich auch okay aber das was er jetzt
macht es was anderes
eigentlich sind musikfans und
liebt die musik die ihm geholfen hat
heimisch zu werden in deutschland erst
mit zehn elf jahren als kind von new
york new jersey nach hamburg über
gesehen und fand es mies
kein baseball mehr das hat ihn wirklich
fertig gemacht keine sonne meer und
dabei wirklich sauer und diese seltsam
connie francis und so aufnahmen der
aufnahmen und diese ganzen rare elements
und die rockies besonders all diese
vergessenen namen
wie haben ihnen das land irgendwie
interessant und lieblich erscheinen
lassen und
mich hat diese musik immer interessiert
weil ich nach verwertbarem suchen nach
nach spuren nach dunkler musikalischer
der name
viele leute machen sich eine ganz
komische vorstellung von den fünfziger
jahren die denken das ist so wie heinz
erhardt film oder so nein aber auch eine
menge gemeinheit und die städte waren
immer noch halb in schutt und asche und
der typ der ein schäfer war ein paar
jahre vorher dein blog watt gewesen auch
da irgendeinen oberstleutnant der
durchhalteparolen geschrieben hat dass
wir jetzt dein chef
das ist eine ziemliche situation die
worte nicht mehr so verstehen dass das
lied mit dem wir ja antreten heißt so
geht das jede nacht und wir können es
als freddy quinn b sollte wir haben
jetzt gelernt dass freddy quinn damit
beim einer der ersten eurovision
wettbewerb angetreten ist damals erst
nicht erster geworden die platzierung
wurden nicht genannt das war nur der
erste genannt wussten wir nicht was als
freddy quinn b sollte und es scheint
niemand zu können das heißt so geht das
jede nacht es handelt davon dass der
mann nicht damit klarkommt dass die frau
so welt ist und man wie reagiert darauf
dass die frau jedes jeden rahmen
hinausgeht
kommt nicht damit klar als es zu viel
für ihn er ist völlig er drehte völlig
durch erzählt auch von als gemacht hatte
ich schenkte er blumen ich für deine
mutter in den zoo wird was dennoch und
so aber sie geht jeden an meinem anderen
aus das ist das muss er erstmal zusammen
kriegen also gibt eine menge zu lachen
aber am titel aber er schlägt aus der
art bei gab es sowas schon mal
an ich war sehr überrascht dass die
meisten heimspiele auch bei unserem
bundesvision denkst du einen wettbewerb
den wir machen und ich sehe dass
weil das ist ja das lied das jahr über
50 jahre alt und das verstößt doch gegen
euro-regeln oh ja stimmt hey wir haben
die regeln geändert kommt er jetzt
ja
das ist natürlich nicht so eine lust
weil ich habe viele 16
liter mit eigenen cds mit eigenen
liedern veröffentlicht doch nicht wieso
nicht eins von diesen liedern wie sony
ericsson b seiten und aber die von dem
plattenlabel meint na sowas für
die pulsadern auf
ok und dann ja das ist genau das habe
ich geantwortet okay dann vielleicht
deshalb drücken wir die daumen damit so
was schlimme ist nicht passiert und die
nummer möglichst weit vorne landet für
niedersachsen und passt auf und es gibt
noch jemand der dir die daumen drückt es
ist martin fischer von dem ich am anfang
geredet habe der einen ziemlich starken
kanal aus niedersachsen hat
martin joost com sie sehen nun ein
motivation video des bundesvision song
contest paten marti fischer für bernd
begemann und der darmstädter für den
inhalt des videos ist allein der
altkanzler zuständig ihre angela merkel
wir müssen wir doch sagen dass wir schon
auf
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
mein name ist gerhard schröder und ich
sitze hier stellvertretend für martin
fischer der eigentlich der pate von dirk
darmstaedter und bernd begemann ist die
dieses jahr beim bundesvision
songcontest für das bundesland
niedersachsen antreten sie gehen mit
ihrem lied so geht das jede nacht an den
start und ich hätte sie bekommen einen
der ersten plätze
ich selbst finde ja die musik die die
beiden machen ganz große klasse denn es
erinnert mich sehr an die flotten
rhythmen von damals das hat mir schon
damals gut gefallen
rufen sie also am ersten oktober beim
bundesvision song contest für die dann
städte und bernd begemann an jungs ich
wünsche euch alles gute und sage
dann kommen hat die fischer es ist immer
gut zu wissen gehört schröder und seiner
russischen oligarchen hinterher zu
wissen also ich denke nicht dass da viel
schiefgehen wird heute beim wettbewerb
und ich denke dass wir mit ein bisschen
anstrengung wenn wir alle zusammen an
einem strang ziehen den 15 platz
erreichen können ich weiß es klingt
verrückt das klingt wie eine
träumerei wie ein verrückter hushovd
pfeifen traum eines jungen mannes aber
echt räumen und dieser traum ist groß
genug für uns alle